i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about the making of a marvel
movie
like black widow you know what i was
surprised at is the conditions that we
shot in
so when we were shooting at pinewood
um the girls were fighting in an
apartment
it was so hot that we continually had to
clear the set um so
some of the scenes you're watching it
they make it look effortless
but uh it was we had some really tough
days
and um you just i mean we had
days shooting with scarlet right at the
end where she had pneumonia
and she kept um she kept going so i
think
what you see on screen is kind of
effortless but i think you
what surprised me was the massive effort
that everyone puts in
so you're saying it's not all glamorous
every day of a movie [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] fight
as we like to say in australia did you
guys ever discuss
making black widow as an r-rated movie
or did that never
come up in conversations no it it did
come up
and i think um i've got a 12 year old
daughter
and i think if you're making a film
about
control and power and you want to uplift
people
i think you want to include adolescents
in that and i think
it would have restricted the message we
wanted to tell
and we didn't want to do that i
completely understand
um was rob hardy ever going to be the
cinematographer or was that just a rumor
we rob was a great collaborator and
um we ended up working with gabrielle
berenstein sure cinematography is great
by the way i just
you know i'm trying to ask a few things
i'm always fascinated by the editing
process because
it is the final rewrite uh so can you
talk a little bit about how long was
your first cut compared to the finished
film
first cut was really really long
um it was probably
twice as long or one and a half of what
it is because the editors put everything
in
sure yeah what well let me ask you were
there
a lot of deleted scenes or was it sort
of um
scenes that you're just like editing out
i guess were there a lot of deleted
scenes
no there wasn't uh can i ask what was
the last thing that you took out of the
movie
before you picture locked and why
do you know what i edited a year ago so
i don't really remember
i was just i just realized that as i'm
saying this this is forever ago for you
you've been yeah
yeah so what actually has this been like
for you because you made a really good
movie
what has it been like waiting for this
thing to come out
peaceful i mean i was with my family in
lockdown in
l.a so it was very quiet and
i think like the rest of us it was
it was winter and we just hunkered down
and yeah it didn't feel the film
felt in another place because everybody
was dealing with the pandemic
and i i think that was right and i think
it feels good now to bring it out
and hopefully we can celebrate that
we're coming out of this
oh 100 uh i don't want to spoil what it
is but you have some footage in the
movie
from another movie was that um tough to
get
can you sort of talk about that without
revealing what it is
uh nothing was tough to get because it's
all part of marvel
and um we didn't use
parts that have screened in other movies
we
used outtakes oh i didn't i didn't
realize that that's really cool
um you obviously every marvel movie is
an after the credit scene was it always
going to be the one that's in the movie
was it ever going to be something else
i don't know i don't know what the what
you're talking about
i'm trying to do this without getting
specific you know to talk around things
um so one of the things though listen i
think that darren prescott was your
second unit director
and he's amazing phenomenal and i wanted
to know could you sort of talk about
what it's like collaborating with a
second unit director in crafting
action in a movie like this darren was
a rock he was like this beautiful
immovable force
and he always had my back and he had
brilliant ideas
and he should be directing his own
movies um
someone needs to give darren a lot of
money and he will make a great movie
um he he is really respected by
all the stunt people and he collaborates
really well
with the fight choreographers so
and he's always pushing it you know he
works really well with vehicles and
he works really well with people um yeah
we had a really good relationship
and yeah i'd love to work with him again
can you actually if you don't mind um
can you talk specifically about crafting
whatever
sequence you want to talk about in terms
of how does it actually work
to deliver what actually ends up on
screen
so in pre-production i made like eight
or nine
short films and some of them were about
uh
fights some one film would be about
fights one would be about
warfare one would be about guerrilla
uh soldiers in childhood
i made all these different films one was
about
the spirit world in that like in nature
like fireflies and things like that
um so that my team
could see what my vision was and then i
also made a hardcover book of images
and so when darren came on board he
could see he could have the script and
he could have
all of those shorts and then he and i
could sit down with the stunt
um choreographers and talk about what
was the essence in the heart of each
fight
or what was the essence of um
like some of the big stunts and then
we'd shot list
it or i'd shot list it and heat shot
list it then we'd come back and meet
and we were sometimes we're on set
together
so it was a very fluid relationship and
um
yeah i learned a lot of him yeah i i
the two of you together did some
fantastic stuff
uh one of the things that i think is so
well done about the movie is it dealing
with very serious stuff
but there's also some really funny
moments in this thing
can you sort of talk about balancing
like you know the the humor
with also all the seriousness
i think if you're down trodden you've
got to laugh you've got to
you've got to poke fun at your jailer
and i think women do that a lot and i
think
um i think the jewish community does it
people of color do it
um so what we wanted was the girls
to be able to laugh at the man and
at what he has done to them and i think
in a funny way alexi becomes like this
um
puppet you know alex is this great
character
character to to pick um to pick fun out
or make fun of
but we knew i mean i wanted the audience
to have a laugh i love having a laugh
and having like people like florence on
set and david especially
um we would sometimes i'd sit behind the
um
split and and cry i mean they're so
gorgeous they gave me um charms with
lines from the film
that's awesome i know so i'm wearing
them today
uh i already have to stop i could ask
you a million other things i just want
to seriously say congratulations
i hope the movie's a huge hit for you
thank you so much